so
um what we're doing so I'm in Hungary we
are a small team like three people full
time and then 500 people helping us out
for an early stage startup our name is
visu and we're specialized in data
visualization most more specifically
we're building a new type of data
visualization tool that has a strong
focus on animation as you can see and
the specialty of the of the whole thing
is that we built an engine that uses a
single logic to generate all different
types of charts and it can interpolate
between the charts that can be expressed
on its interface and that results in a
very flexible uh like these kind of
capabilities that are showcased with
this nice animation
uh and uh we are obviously looking for
uh use cases and audiences who are you
know at this point have the skills and
the experience to to put this technology
to good use
uh technologically speaking the the core
engine is in C plus plus uh we use a web
assembly to enable it in the browser uh
we I mean at first it had a very obscure
scripting language it was only myself
and the other guys who had to struggle
with that then we built uh JavaScript
API and we released an open source
JavaScript library and just basically
using the same technology as plotly does
we released a python API uh this July so
like a couple of months ago when I was
doing a presentation at the Euro python
in Dublin uh and so that thing is why
I'm here for uh it it runs in a Jupiter
notebook and similar computational
notebooks it runs already in streamlit
uh in in data breaks uh you can use it
in panel and well there you can even
build a dashboard to it in mode so there
are already plenty of applications
and uh yeah for today I thought uh I
would give you uh an introduction like a
practical deeper introduction to the
whole thing and I even have sort of like
a challenge that we could work on
together and uh if we do a good job some
of us or some of you might even be able
to you know a couple of thousands of
bucks I'm not the one providing that
money but kaggle does but uh but I have
a like you know I prepared something for
you it's a it's a fun thing it might be
really powerful or it might be just some
things you take uh half of your morning
with
so before I go deeper I would love to
know like uh who you are uh and like a
couple of you know hands up type of
questions so how many of you are working
as data scientists
all right almost everybody
uh I guess all of you are using uh
Jupiter notebook right anybody who
doesn't okay good you what what do you
use
ah okay so you don't uh waste time with
the notebook then okay uh as I said I'm
not a data scientist so I wouldn't say I
understand the importance of this but
still our stuff works in Python too
there's like some special stuff you have
to do as preparations but it works hi
come join us
okay how many of you were President
yesterday when I did the uh like this
short lightning talk about Donald
Trump's tweets
okay half of the room uh was it the
reason you came
ah good good perfect uh we'll we'll uh
we have the chance to take a look at the
code of that thing as well
um all right
um and so you're working as data
scientists how many of you have to
present your findings to non-data
scientists so like business stakeholders
like let's say okay
more than once per month
okay like three four people uh
more than twice per month
yeah it's still the same four people
okay uh we made some surveys about it
and it varies a lot so there are people
who have to do that regularly there are
people who don't have to do it really
and then there are data scientists
working on the scientific field who are
really averse to presenting anything not
to mention it doesn't it has to be black
and white and not animated at all that
seem that that is a like an Insight we
gathered along the
okay uh I uh I put all the materials uh
into uh a GitHub folder if you go to
bit.li slash I5 visual hyphen Workshop
uh you'll have all the notebooks that
we're going through uh and the data that
we're going to fiddle with so I thought
you know because of the workshop setting
it's much easier for you not to just you
know follow my uh yeah as I'm going
through the code but you can already
start manipulating it breaking it I
don't know building something new uh and
uh
so it's it's just easier like that
um
do you have any questions requests
comments as of this point
okay let's jump in then uh so
basically because of this this generic
nature that that visual employs uh the
how the interface looks it's it's just
one uh method the animate method that
you have to call over and over again
when you call it first it's going to
give you a static chart when you call it
again it will animate to the chart that
you described for the second time it
sounds easy but you know as you can
imagine with something rather early
stage maintained by a small group and
trying to we are trying to figure our
way out there are some limitations and
things to keep in mind uh I will I will
get to that too but but basically that's
that's the basic logic of it uh it has
uh three uh parameters uh data config
and style uh you add the data to it you
set up the chart that's the config part
and then you have a plethora of
different opportunities to to you know
use the style that you you intend to do
and you can even fill with the
animations like how the engine moves
from one state to the other actually
very few people start experimenting with
that we we really try to make everything
very straightforward by default but but
we are happy to you know take Insight on
on that too uh it looks like half of the
room already started skipping through
all the material that I put there so
that they'll be gone in 10. no hopefully
not
um okay so let's see a very simple
example we're going to use the Titanic
data data set for that uh we use pandas
and from ipivizu that you can install
with either pip or conda Forge we are
going to use chart data confidence style
parameters and we are just going to read
the Titanic data set as a CSV and edit
to so create the data object and edit
add the data frame to the data object
that's about it I think it's fairly
straightforward and uh yeah we can take
a look at how uh whether it was yeah we
have the data set and I mean I I think
you're all very familiar with the with
it so no no time need to be spent on
that now we create the chart in the next
cell uh we can set the width and the
height uh with either percentages or
pixels there are a couple of other
options but that's basically the most
important too and we build our first
chart by adding the count so which is an
extra uh series that we added here it's
like one in each row uh on the x-axis
and add the add sex to the y-axis uh add
something to the label and then at the
table add the title to the Chart uh what
do you think what what we're going to
see when I run this cell any ideas
hmm
a bar chart yeah absolutely it's it's a
simple bar chart uh the on the x-axis
it's the
it's the count so the number of people
and it's split by male and female uh and
uh yeah in the next phase
uh that's a great question uh the
default is uh so I will get into it in
more detail but the geometry of the
rectangular geometry we have Circle we
have line we have area and also the uh
euclidean geometry so we have euclidean
and polar and so if you don't specify
those it's going to be a bar chart or a
column chart uh and uh because those are
the most common uh
in this in that regard we have defaults
for every setting and you can change all
of those either this way or through
presets that I'm going to show you so
it's it's just like you know we we try
to
get like build this experience or give
this experience of building a chart with
just four lines of code uh so there are
some defaults that you don't set here
but you're obviously good to go so I
mean I if I just add uh I don't know
geometry let's yeah let's
the circle
it's going to be like two dots here so
it the positions are the same but it's a
circular chart obviously this use case
is much better for for a bar chart uh
and then so in the next phase thank you
for your question mother so in the next
phase what I'm going to do is add
survives on the x-axis and everything
basically stays the same but I also add
survived on the color any guesses now
what we will end up with
so we will have in the previous stage we
had uh only count on the x-axis now we
have survived and we also have it on the
color
stack yeah it's it's going to be a
stacked uh bar chart and visual will
animate the transition between the
unit and as the third and final phase of
this super simple example is we are just
going to remove the survive series from
the x-axis and edit on the y-axis
um any guesses what's going to happen
multiple yeah multiple bar charts is
actually this uh activity is called I
mean there are it's interesting that
there are no there's no grammar for
these transitions there are a couple of
uh
yeah like experiments and directions and
people coming from the data
visualization space have some sort of a
language for that data scientists have a
different sort of language and we are
actually trying to figure it out with
with people like you uh and and build
sort of a grammar of animated graphics
uh and and this is called grouping uh
this this activity when uh basically we
just group uh the elements on the on the
y-axis and and that's that
um
okay so uh that was the the first
example uh let's talk a little bit about
the config part of uh of the of the
chart because that's like where the
magic happens and that's the most uh
complex part of the whole uh the whole
thing so you can have uh you we have the
access X and Y and we have uh channels
uh such as the color label size
lightness and nuke or nope uh I think uh
I'm pretty sure you both understand what
x and y means uh size color label
lightness anybody having any questions
regarding what they might do
okay and nope so it means it's we are
going to use that it's a it's a special
channel that uh won't affect any
characteristics of the markers just uh
have you'll have more than if you you
know if you add any series to these
channels it means you have more markers
and it also affects the characteristics
of the markers there are vertical or
horizontal position they're you know how
they look and and what's written on them
and and so on and so forth with nope
it's just you have as many markers
elements on the chart uh as many
categories basically you have on the
categorical series that you add to the
chart and nope just enables you to do
that without changing any other uh
characteristic of the of the charts I
know it's very theoretical at this point
I will give you an example that will be
very straightforward actually it happens
all the time that we have a like a very
good understanding of the nitty-gritty
details of the Logics behind any kind of
charts whereas you have a lot of
experience in actually you know
practically applying those and and we
are working towards uh being on the same
level with you uh it's not the other way
around that you have to understand what
we do but I always end up trying to
explain it because I'm so enthusiastic
about it sorry about that
uh so we have the coordinate system as I
mentioned the geometry I already talked
about uh we have uh we can sort uh
we can sort the elements on the chart so
you know make it like from smallest to
largest and things like that we can
align the elements uh towards any axis
you can add the title just like it is
here so it was you know title passengers
of the Titanic and it appeared on the
charts so it's just that and we have
this specific thing called split that
I'm going to show you and also a special
type of alignment that's called stretch
so uh yeah let's build another chart and
and we'll see some examples so it's
going to be chart two you can have
multiple charts in the same notebook as
you can see and what we are going to do
here is I think we start with the same
chart no this one yeah
that we saw before and we are just going
to experiment with the Align stretch
thing uh which is doing this
so it it stretches the alignment and
with via this you can basically compare
values versus percentages uh as you can
see the the scale adapts to this so it's
already personally just shown on the
scale uh it's not a person that's just
shown on the labels though and it's
something you have to do in the
background so like add the percentages
to your data frame and because visual is
automatically summing up the elements so
you know in the data frame there were
like everybody had a count of one and
still we saw that there are 233 uh women
who are survived the crash so you know
it adds up all the elements in the count
Series so if you want to add something
like that a percentage you have to also
split it among the elements that are
being shown on the chart it's a little
tricky I will give you examples to that
too but basically uh because of the the
stage that we're in there are a couple
of things that you have to do uh on the
data in the data frame we are already
working on the the new version of the
engine where this would be just the
parameter and it would also be capable
of uh using different uh like simple
calculations not just some but mean and
you know minimum and things like that
right now it's still a bit of a little
bit of effort on that side
all right and if I just uh add uh let's
see
um yeah I I have an example for that in
this in the next slide but why not so if
I had split uh true which I mentioned is
also like a specific type of yeah and I
have to just turn the alignment back to
previous version I mean the normal ones
the line
this then you can see that this what the
split does so it basically enables you
to compare the the components of Stack
charts side by side with the Trump
example it was you know when we had the
trend of of all the tweets and then we
were able to see just you know the
retweets the replies and the original
tweets uh with like one animation uh we
will have it in in the examples that
come up next
questions at this point
yes please
um
uh yeah it's a great question thanks so
the question was whether we can specify
the uh the the order uh via which uh the
the elements are are ordered or sorted
uh so visu right now is capable of uh
taking on and I think I mentioned here
but I forgot to talk about it uh so any
number of categorical and one numerical
series that's true for the axis and the
channels as well so in most cases charts
would only have one numerical uh added
to them that's actually very true for
for all the charts that that you're
using except for uh like Scatter Plots
and and bubble plots where actually
sorting doesn't make too much sense uh
you you because you know the position of
the markers on the X and the y-axis uh
is like a value so you don't want to
change that it only makes sense if you
have categories on one axis and a value
on the other axis to to rearrange and
sort the elements and that can only be
like one value at the
uh which actually I don't think any
charting libraries do it differently but
prove me wrong it might be just that I
don't
all righty uh any more questions
let's move on to another example and you
know it gets more and more complex and
uh we'll see uh where it takes us okay
so
it's gonna be the results of a LinkedIn
poll that we took in uh five or six no
five different groups where data
scientists uh or visit often and
basically the beginning it's it's you
know pretty much the same so there's
nothing interesting about that
we set the the chart uh parameters again
we add the data to the chart and we are
going to use one this thing here that is
uh crucially important or like it opens
up a new set of nifty opportunities to
to show your data which is uh to add a
filter to your data so we have a six or
so the five different groups but because
I add data dot filter and and add this
thing here it will only the the chart
will only show uh the data from group
number one so it's easy as that and we
set up the uh yeah I mean you're all
really familiar with with uh with
everything that that's here and we also
use just a little bit of padding for the
for the Legend So if I run this cell
I'll end up with with a stacked bar
chart where we have already the the
information there but there's just one
group uh that is being shown and and in
the next phase I'm just going to turn
that filter off by using data filter
none I'm not sure so zoom in a bit a
little bit so that you can see it and
and if I if I run this cell uh
the all the other groups appear
so it's it's a great way to just you
know explain what you're about to show
without uh like you know confusing the
audience and and them trying to uh
understand and and decipher all the
different categories out there it's just
you can you can build a complex chart
it's not that complex but still one by
one we actually like to do it like you
know when we want to build
kind of like a bubble plot which is uh
considered a pretty complex chart for
most people we add dimensions and values
one by one so it's just easier to follow
and and get acquainted with the chart
and obviously the the whole thing about
animation is that it makes it easier for
people to follow along a story so
storytelling is is one of the the aspect
that we're focusing on right now we
actually have a vision of of building a
graphical user interface uh built on
charts but that's for the basic business
users so I'm not going to come back and
show it to you because obviously your
analytical skills and and a know-how is
is like Way Beyond that but but this is
so I just want to make it clear that
that this whole IPython thing that we do
is is uh is an important uh like stage
on our journey and the the opportunity
to to work together with you and
identify buying the benefits and use
cases over Tech is is what brought us
here and and also the opportunity that
you are skilled enough to to be able to
utilize this technology whereas
obviously end users don't stand a chance
at the moment they have to they would
have to start coding yes please
yeah it's it is similar in some sense uh
but uh but our tool is built uh probably
from the ground up so uh we because of
the generic nature you could actually
you know build syntaxes uh around it or
on top of it we I mean I'm I keep on
thinking we should have a matplotlib
sort of dictionary or something to to
enable people to just use their their
matplotlib charts and animate them with
vizu uh would that make sense to you
oh great the
just for the record some people noted
their heads
yes please
no it sums it up uh and because of that
we had to uh like calculate it
beforehand and add it to the data frame
so we have number of votes here and uh
well we didn't do it in data frame I
will show you examples when I do that
but about uh somewhere else but we we
also had the percentages to the you know
the this is like here's a group now a
group name here's a group like coded
with a number here's a
an answer here is the the votes uh in
that group for that answer so it's just
a number here is like how many people
voted on that answer in that group and
then uh we have like okay how many votes
were casted on the on that group all
together so as you can see it repeats
here and then we calculate like from the
total percentage uh for the for
everybody in every group how much
actually is for this group if we go
through the story I know it sounds it's
a little uh sounds a little complicated
but when we go through the story it's
going to be very clear
um yeah in this place it is just a
simple example
last example meaning this one or
yeah uh okay so this one
yeah yeah it the same thing is happening
in the background so basically uh we
have now okay so let's see uh in group
five two or more per month uh has 39
okay and you can see it right here so
this is this is that marker there's
nothing to sum up here because we are to
the most granular level of the data
frame and uh when we go uh like more
like when we forward in the story you
will see that that we will start adding
certain elements uh so but that's a
great question I know it's it's a you
have to understand this this logic that
you employ so thank you very much for
that
okay in the uh
next phase I'm just turning on splitting
it actually makes more sense with these
many elements uh so you know everybody
can compare how uh what what the
percentages was per different answer in
all the groups and then in the next
phase uh we just switch uh the and add
the vote count instead of the the vote
percentage so that's that's actually
something I think very powerful uh to
change the the value being shown on the
chart I did it yesterday with with
Trump's like number of tweets versus
number of times these were retweeted uh
visual always very nicely animates when
you when you change the a continuous
series uh even like for example if you
have a scatter plot and you change the
the value on any of the axis then the
the little dots or you know the the
circles will just move to their new
position it's very easy to to follow uh
one or more elements like where they go
or or understand changes in in
um yeah how they are scattered across
the the plots and things like that
um
and so the next stage is uh what when
we're adding up we the uh the elements
uh so
yeah like this and it did it
automatically but as you can see I call
the animate method twice
not just once in this step there is an
important uh like uh
reason behind it so as you can see in
the first animate it was group and vote
count on the y-axis and then it was only
vote count
the reason I do this is because when you
remove a category from a chart or when
you add a category to a chart it will
split up the markers and as of now and I
think for maybe the next months visual
won't automatically just know from which
so how to remove that extra category or
how to edit in a way that it's so super
easy to follow for the viewer and
because of that it will fade
uh I had many people who were super
enthusiastic about using our technology
ending up publishing something where the
chart was fading between two stages
instead of animating and my co-founder
who was actually coming up with the
whole concept behind this zoo was just
tearing his hair out one by one for
seeing that but it makes a lot of sense
I mean why would people know that we
have this kind of logic behind the whole
thing it's us who have to enable them
enable you not to think about it but
still right now and for the next month
you have to think about it and whenever
you see your charts fading instead of
animating from one stage to the other
that is what's happening that's
basically no other reason for that okay
you change the categories and when we're
doing this and and you would have hi
welcome and when you will have uh some
experience like that just let me know
I'll be there to help you out okay
it's it's fairly easy to to but it might
not come naturally like what is going on
here but if it fades just let me know
that will be the issue
okay and uh as the uh
now now we are changing again to Total
percentage and uh just uh going back to
your previous question uh so we are now
adding up these elements so 3.9 percent
it's somewhere here in the in the in the
46 percent of 45 that's in the chart
does it make sense
uh yeah and so right now this is the
only thing it can do and we are working
on adding more uh like simple
calculations as I said uh to the engine
so that you can uh you know just pick
mean or minimum or any other thing like
that uh it just requires uh like some
investment and as I said we're a
three-man team plus uh five uh
part-timers so and and also this text
setup it works really nicely and
everything but getting contributors uh
who can work on C plus plus engine that
will help some other people using a
python package uh it's it's not that
straightforward to say the least uh
having people like you to to build
examples and uh and and experiment with
our stuff in in different environments
that makes total sense but adding
features like this it's a lot harder
yeah and then you can actually we
already have the thing where you can
just you know click on different markers
and select them sadly this selection
won't stay there when you animate from
one face to the other we will edit so we
know it's it's like the the most uh
mind-blowing thing is that we had it in
the Prototype uh but uh when we had to
you know uh do the production grade
engine our CTO said that it has to wait
a little bit he's like super keen on on
making robust stuff and and then in
backward compatibility and everything so
it's it's great on the long term but me
standing on the product side I'm being
the CEO of the company by the way so
basically you know at the three-person
company it's like doing everything
business related and stuff uh so uh I
I'm just like I I need that function I
know people will love it
um there are ways around it uh via
coding but uh but obviously it will
become much more natural if you just
click on certain elements and then you
see the same stuff in different views
all right and let's switch to Polar
coordinates and what we'll end up with
is everybody's favorite
a pie chart uh
would you have thought that a pie chart
is basically a stacked single bar chart
in polar coordinates
uh not not many people think about it
that way uh we constantly do
there this was the initial uh interface
that we released and it's uh it has a
couple of challenges as you can see
because and and the challenges are not
only the ones that I mentioned but uh
one is that the generic logic can be
hard to comprehend this like putting uh
you know series categories and values to
different x's and channels you might not
know what you end up with uh even though
we I think fit in nicely with the
notebook environment and you can
obviously experiment but uh when you're
working this is not what you want to do
you don't want the experiment you just
want the scatter plot so I want to build
a scatter plot you want the stack bar
chart and you don't want to figure it
out like in what setting would that work
for you that's what every data scientist
told us when we released the initial
version of this this March and also the
one directional use so if I call like
this uh cell again nothing is happening
and if I call this one again then
something very strange happens so we
didn't go back to the previous state uh
but you know the the the code was called
on the state on the on the final state
of of the chart and it changed the
settings somehow and now we have a chart
that we might not even be able to uh
interpret it's it's basically a a column
chart that is uh in the polar
coordinates by the way but uh but still
uh it's it's not handy so uh we we try
to address those issues in the recent
months and and started working on on
adding uh presets and we have now over
40 of these so if you go on our site uh
it's like uh you have to go to
ipivizu.com and uh
then you will have a tutorial that's on
this side by the way and also there'll
be examples right beneath the logo it
looks like the internet is
uh so these are the these are the
presets and if you click on any of the
uh of the examples here uh you'll end up
with some code and you can see that for
example this is config percentage bar
here so it's not config just config
anymore but you can pick the chart type
via like this and and decide what you
want to build it has a even a more
simple syntax so you still put something
on the axis but I think that's the part
what's pretty straightforward and you
just add you want to Stack it by another
category and uh and a personage bar
chart you don't have to add a line
stretch like you would have in the
original version you didn't have to add
Joy factors to the color like you would
have to in the original version so it's
it's a lot simpler and and there are a
couple of these uh
these bracelets as I said around 40. uh
we are happy to add more so if you have
a chart type that you don't see here but
you use pretty often I would be
surprised but uh but I would love to
hear about it and you know we can add it
in a couple of days uh and these are
these are all uh presets here also we
have uh we have static charts with the
old interface that you can take a look
at and we have we have animated charts
so like simple transitions uh as
examples learned from that you can check
out on our site and we even have
we even have uh everybody's favorite
from uh three years ago uh uh like the
racing bar chart uh but uh we added
something on top of it so that that
other libraries and solutions can do
this is obviously the racing part it
shows how much revenue different music
form is generated here in the US between
the 1950s I think up to 2020 and yeah
this way of aggregating the whole data
set and then showing it how it spreads
across time sorry since 1973 so it's
something that you cannot really do with
another other type of Library especially
not with these many lines of code
okay uh I would go to a preset example
if uh but again happy to answer any
questions you might have yeah please
thanks God
um okay so most of the things are
basically out of box uh so you can just
run this amount of code that you saw
mm-hmm
uh
uh yes
uh HTML it we were driving we're writing
so like drawing things on the canvas and
uh so we are getting the to the point
where you would have the same
interactive story uh telling and
presentation stuff that I showcased
yesterday with with the Trump thing uh
and you can just export an HTML out of
that and send it to anyone
no
uh it's it's a it's an animated
interactive HTML5
uh you weren't there with the with the
Trump presentation that's all right uh
so it's it's you it's interactive you
can go back and forth between these
slides because that was the the other
issue that we had that is mentioned here
is the one directional use uh we already
have a solution for that and I'm getting
there I promise it's going to be more
handy uh in 15 minutes it's just
basically the our uh yeah I'm also
showing you our story so like how we got
here I think it's the best way to
understand the how how this thing
currently works and thanks for the
question I hope uh yeah again in like 10
minutes of time you will have a uh like
these kind of yeah you will feel that
this is easy to use and utilize in in
your in your life okay quick yeah please
no no no uh with the with the
storytelling interface uh it's not only
it's not one directional it's
bi-directional it's a presentation uh
that that's going to be the next example
pinky promise
yeah
okay uh but just want to show you how
the presets work because then again
these are all used in the in the
storytelling stuff as well and and I
think it's just better to go step by
step
um
so right now we have a data frames
surprise surprise it's about how much
revenue music form is generated in the
US so uh sadly I already blew the whole
story sorry about that and we are just
adding a bar chart here uh so this is
something you saw uh in the animated
version and then because it doesn't look
so well we switch to grouped bar chart
uh which we will Group by format which
is on the y-axis as well and one more
example of how we use styling is that we
add colors to it like this so we use the
style perimeter we say plot marker color
palette add the list of colors and there
you go instead of the colors that you
saw before so which is the default one
you have a new palette that this is
already working there it actually makes
a lot of sense to change color palettes
within a longer story for example
because when you're showing different
categories you don't want people to
think that it's still the same okay
category that you showed before
and yeah so like a couple of things we
do here again rearrange the chart uh
just edit so this is also an interim
step I added here on the x-axis you
don't see anything about it but it's an
interim step required to avoid anime uh
fading when I go here so I can actually
show you an example of how it looks when
the whole thing Fades so let's go back I
think I have to start over again to make
sure that we end up with the view that
we were looking for a group bar chart to
the previous you know but whatever and I
skipped this step okay the the this one
and go right to here so as you could see
it faded it didn't do the nice animation
the nice transition from one state to
the other sorry it was like I guess two
it wasn't seeing on the screen so yeah
it faded backwards again
um
like this
whenever you see something like this
it's it's because of the categories okay
uh you have the opportunity to add event
handlers I'm not going to be go into the
details but these are just too many
years written on the x-axis it's really
not looking very nice and uh this is
just three lines of code or five
altogether that would uh tell the the
system to only write the years when they
are divisible by five and if I go there
it's like that it's all the others are
gone so there are plenty of different
opportunities to to fine-tune your
graphics to make it make them look nicer
you try to make them look nice out of
box but you know there are we can just
prepare for all the different kind of
settings and we will switch now to the
stream graph
be yeah sorry the animation is keep
happening outside of screen I do the
splitting again these are all things
you're very familiar with then I do the
filtering thing once again uh you can
use so it's not python syntax I know
it's JavaScript syntax with the filter
meaning you have an extra
equal sign and an extra or sign and the
height so like the hyphens are at this
it's a little different place uh sorry
about that but yeah I'm pretty sure he
would be able to figure it out so this
is another way of using the filtering
stuff is zoom in on certain elements
it's it's a very simple feature I think
it's super powerful in storytelling it
really works well now when we switch the
filter off that comes my my wife's
favorite part she calls it when the
elephants are kissing
yeah
and uh and here we go we just gonna
change this to a line chart by using
config line and it means we are able to
compare the trends side by side because
you lines are not stacked on top of each
other okay we I that's that's the way
how we uh like try to address the
generic logic thing and then comes the
one directional use case thing so uh
this is what we released it's a new
extension called I5 is a story it's in a
separate repo so I have all the links
for the repos in the year uh at the
folder that I shared with you if you can
give us Stars we'd love to have that so
it's iPad this one iPad is a story two
different repositories you have to add
both when you're using I5 as a story
it's about it uh again we're using
pandas and we're going to build a story
about
um
the federal r d budget how much money
the US government spent on different
stuff that is considered r d uh as you
can see defense is one of them so it had
and then Healthcare is another so uh no
those are asking very different things
but they all fall under the the r d
budget and uh this is just an example of
a more complex style that we add to the
Chart we we just create a separate
object where we add all the different
settings for the different parameters so
it's like plot y-axis label the font
size should look like this the right
padding should look like this uh the the
title color is is uh basically vanished
so because uh the last two bits uh tell
you the uh
the transparency so set to zero it's not
going to be there and a couple of things
like that I actually have uh prepared
and it's also the link is in the
uh
again in the in the readme of that
folder that I shared with you uh the
spreadsheet for you where you can just
go through the the hierarchical logic of
our style settings and for example this
is plot this is open here you can open
and close it I I would suggest you to
make a copy of it by the way uh then
because I think as a viewer you might
not be able to close and open these
things so I just opened plot and here's
the x-axis and here's the label and I
would say I will just want to change the
font size it's pretty straightforward
the code that I you have to write might
not be out of like At first so if you
say like I want the the font size to be
one VW instead the the sheets will just
generate that one line of code for you
to make your life easier and and you can
use yeah pixels EMS
viewport width and height and so to make
your visualization more responsive or
percentages everything that's in in HTML
um
[Music]
so we just added as a separate object
and we add it to the story because right
now we have a story
and we we had data and style to it and
uh yeah so
um
I think
yeah just to
go one by one so we have ipive is a
story and we have the story the slide
and the step element
uh these are in hierarchical order the
story is the whole story a slide is a
view of the chart or the data where you
stop and a step so because so for
example The Fading between the the
different categories uh there might be
occasions when you want to add more
steps between slides so a slide can have
more steps that's basically a list of
config chart configurations that would
take you to the final step of that slide
which is the one that you want to end up
at it's it's that easy uh just uh so
there's a lot of code here uh but I'm
just going to
like compared to the the things that we
saw before so let's see the the first
two slides it says oh yeah I forgot to
run this cell sorry and yeah so the way
this looks is we have a chart here we
can toggle it to full screen it will
scale up nicely and you have these
controls beneath you can go to the next
few back to the first view uh you can
add slides one by one you can actually
use a clicker to go through your slides
or a page now page Nam buttons or your
arrow buttons and then it runs right
from The Notebook uh the full screen
button doesn't always work in different
environments uh like databricks and
collabs where because you know we we
open a canvas where we generate the
charts onto and they put the canvas into
an iframe and the content in an iPhone
can go full screen so don't be surprised
if you find that but uh Jupiter notebook
for example it works nicely in
streamlined it works perfectly well and
and in some other platforms as well so
uh yeah and uh so a simple example we
create the story we add the data and the
style to it again we set the size just
like we did with the chart and then we
start adding slides so the first slide
is a slide it has a single step it has
filtering so basically this part it's
the same as we saw before it's
absolutely the same iPad as a syntax
that you I assume already very familiar
with uh and uh
it's just like this is one step and then
we add this slide with the single step
to the story by calling the add slide
method that's about it and the Second
Step I'll just add the split true method
again a single step slide and add it to
the slide and uh and play the story so
that it appears right beneath the cell
uh the other the one line of code I
haven't explained is this story set
feature tooltip true which will mean
that we have this interactive tooltip by
hovering your mouse over your chart it
will just show the data right beneath it
it has some separate style settings and
everything it shows all the data that
even the ones that are not maybe shown
by the markers hi welcome
um so uh and I'll just again use a
Handler because I really don't like that
all the years are written in an
overlapping fashion and the third slide
it's going to be a multi-step slide so I
just create the slide like this and I
add one step uh where I just turn the
splitting thing off that's this bit of
code does and then I will just switch
off the filter uh and Via that at the
defense budget because originally the
filter was set in a way that it includes
everything but defense
so if I run this cell and here's Story
play again I will start with the same
slide so it always starts with the with
the first slide but I can go right away
to the last one that I just added so
it's easier to look what you just built
and yeah we have defense uh you spend
quite a lot on defense or like the us
over the years as you can see
um
so uh a couple of more slides that we
had here I really don't want to take up
all your time me talking so I'm just
going to add those uh all together and
and show you a couple of
features you have the notebook uh in in
the in the repo so it's easy for you and
if you have any questions uh concerning
the code so that's where we started uh
we split it so we can see the trends
obviously space was huge in the 60s
Healthcare is growing uh basically
uh constantly uh and uh yeah there's
defense which again just it's just the
filtering the zooming effect you keep
the context but the story had a like it
took a different turn right uh you can
again show the percentages so you know
you can see actually the the share of
defense is decreasing uh over time it
was a lot bigger uh like in the Reagan
Era when you know space War plans and
whatnot and again we are just using the
filtering stuff but we now filtered not
a category but uh but the years and we
filtered the the first year and last
year so and by grouping the things which
is something we've done before we can
just compare uh different components and
how they changed over time that's about
it you or you have an interactive
presentation and and you can just call
yeah it's not here for some reason but
let me show you so
yeah you can
it's basically yeah it's like this story
export to HTML
uh and just name it and you have the
interactive HTML with the data in it you
can send it in an email you can upload
it to your company server everybody will
have the interactive story
and not the notebook so you can share it
with people who would be scared Away by
one line of code there's usually one
thing that I change with the HTML that I
generate from such a story and it's that
uh as you remember we we set the size of
the story in a way that it's 100 on the
width and 400 pixel height and usually I
just changed in the HTML to be 100 in
the hype as well so it takes up all the
screen when they open it on mobile and
everything that's all it's it's
much better and one other thing I wanted
to raise your attention to is that when
we read the data we actually use the
d-type function of pandas to this to
tell it that year is actually a string
because here is a value and if vizu
thinks it's a value your charge will
look quite strange so it will think that
you have two values that's that's going
to be a chart so it's it's going to be
something but figuring out what what is
going on it might be a little harder
all right that was the frontal part uh
I'm I'd be very happy to see you just I
don't know stand up and do a little bit
of like I don't know just
you know to get your blood flowing maybe
we should all do that but I've been
standing but really I'm sitting here for
people
don't tell you
so I I would definitely encourage you to
in some cases I asked the audience to
just start massaging each others
are you into that I'm not sure no you're
not
um
anyhow so uh yeah I promised you the
chance of winning some money right
yeah yeah questions sorry
yeah
yeah absolutely it's basically it's
almost similar to the to the uh to this
and I think I yeah it is the Trump story
and I intentionally added an empty slide
in the beginning it's the same story
that I showed you yesterday so that you
know nicely fades in when I start a
presentation but yeah as you can see it
actually doesn't adapt right away
there's like one interaction needs to be
done uh like moving your mouse over it
and as you can see it scales and
actually it scales in an animated
fashion uh if you change the style
settings to like grow the font size and
everything we do that also in an
animated way so uh it's it's a single
engine that's that's what it does so we
try to use the capabilities when you
change the width and height of the
panels because there are like the
Legends part and the titles part and the
plots part that's happening in an
animated fashion as well uh so uh yeah
that's that's our strength I guess
any other questions yeah a lot wow great
thanks uh let's start here and go over
there right we have time for all of this
thank you
um yeah you can say so
yes yes absolutely you describe the
chart absolutely the same way as you did
with the with the chart animate function
the only thing that you cannot do with
the story a bit is to add new data with
the with the with the original version
even though it wasn't in the examples
you can add new elements or even new
series so like extend the data frame
that is being handled in the background
uh and uh just like with the zooming in
out so with the filtering this would
make space for the new elements to
appear and everything or ipivizu so it
works nicely with the stories because
actually in the background all the
different views along the story are
generated so that you have this leak
okay I'm going back and forth between
them it's not like on the fly like with
the uh with the notebook cells uh
there's no way you can add data to it as
of now
but it's unfortunately it's totally the
same thanks for the question yeah uh
there was two oh yeah I mean you were
the one so this lady sitting behind you
but you'll be nice
one to ten
uh you can you can absolutely do it in a
loop
yeah yeah it could work yes uh I haven't
tried it so uh we still have time and
actually the the remaining part of the
this session is about uh
working independently or in small teams
uh trying uh visu so uh please give it a
go and and let me know how it goes as I
said I'm not a data scientist myself so
I might have issues but together with
with everybody around here I'm pretty
sure we'll figure it out and for example
with the uh the racing bar chart that's
a loop uh so that's that's a loop
calling the animate method in a very
quick fashion uh with the filtering and
it's just the the time frame for the
animation is uh narrowed down to I think
0.2 milliseconds 0.2 seconds or
something so that you know it really
quickly happens uh that's one thing that
you don't have in the in the
storytelling bit as of now the animation
options so it's as it is we will add it
but
we don't have it right now
okay sorry uh that was a question you
have a question oh yeah that's perfect
sorry
context manager I'm not sure what it
does but let's try it
um yeah I think you can do that I
haven't tried it you can actually add
the slides at the very end so you just
create them and you know you add it
before you you hit story play that's
like an easy way to go uh I'm pretty
sure you can actually make the the code
uh even more compact with a couple of
Tricks I'm just as I said not a
developer myself so I'm using the the
vanilla version
foreign
yeah yeah absolutely and uh and also
yeah short answer yes
that's a really interesting question so
uh
right now this whole thing is uh capable
of of beer you can build linear stories
with it you're right about that so you
can go on one track back and forth and
uh we don't think that uh moving forward
is the way forward is to add uh
Crossroads in this linear path but
rather to add the opportunity for the
end user to interact with the views so
for example uh like switch on split
switch on and off that specific function
and it makes sense so that you don't
have to code those slides independently
and it's just an option for anyone
viewing the charge or to switch between
values and and percentages that's also
something fairly straightforward and
there are a couple of things like that
so we call it guided exploration the way
we see it is that right now you are the
creators so you are the people who can
actually build such stories using our
technology and then there are the
viewers the business people who would
you know look at it and try to
understand uh what the results of your
analysis or something about their
business or you know things like that
and and we want to enable this sort of
guided exploration when people like you
create them the initial views but they
can you know
in a limit its way but but still explore
the data and look for insights on their
own using these animated charts that
obviously make it as we hope quite easy
to to you know look through the their
data and keep context and understand
what they're looking at and use it as
sort of like an interactive dashboard or
report when the data is becoming like
less static and more like a stream of
data and things like that so that's that
was a great question we don't think it's
about multilinear storytelling but
rather exploration
okay uh there are a couple of people out
there but we're good vaccine please
yes uh I'll I'll send you a but I think
you know it's a fairly straightforward
it should be
we have one that we builds and then
there's uh a guy in the streamlit
Creator Community called Opera uh he
built a couple of other examples it
works nicely there are a couple of
issues we're facing with the sizing
stream it only takes a big sell widths
and Heights uh and uh yeah it's actually
the about the presentation because it's
a similar survey that I showed you the
results of the story is totally the same
uh how people prepare a content in
Jupiter to presented most people
screenshot it and add it to PPT do you
do that
it's a viable option I don't have any
issues with that it's just
I I hope to uh that we will have like oh
I'm using these words
why would I use anything else so yeah
it's iPad is a story at streamlit.com uh
no sorry
let me try and
put it somewhere where you can
see it
there you go
just type it in and there there it is
and the other stuff while we're talking
that that yeah I do and there was a like
a flame about it right yeah
yeah that was it uh it was us uh it and
uh so on Reddit uh honestly uh we have
over 40 million views and 200 000
upvotes with the stories that we built
uh and then there are the cases when uh
we we come to pushy like it seems that
for the data scientists uh subreddit it
was a bit too much it's a simple story
and it seemed like we were mocking
PowerPoint and I don't know there's
people some people had a very strange
reaction and it was taken down but if
you go and look for visual HQ on Reddit
you can see actually a couple of Stories
We built uh about the former shares of
chocolate bar and uh about uh yeah
different things uh the election
forecast in 2020
um
the faith of the turn of the Liquidators
things like that
um yeah but that's a different thing
um
for the stories in on Reddit uh there
there are some bits where we added some
video editing but
most of it's like 95 of it is visual uh
you should understand that this was way
back so in very previous versions of the
thing we even built uh so for the Trump
bit I have uh I have an interactive
actually something that does this guided
exploration or shows a good example of
that uh it is the same thing that I
showed yesterday but uh
take some it's it's a new
so
this
hmm
you want to export Donald Trump's tweets
uh I I can I can send you the link
this is and and the way so the
technology behind it it's outdated it's
it's a very old version but it's a good
example of uh of these guided
Explorations so when you add buttons
this is something that people would
definitely be able to follow along and
understand uh what's going on this is
yeah the when we switch from and it's a
little slower and there are a couple of
issues with the animations here but
there's like more like you know there's
a guy who uh try to categorize which are
the tweets that Trump himself sent and
which are the ones that that his staff
at some point in time his staff started
to add typos and all caps words to avoid
such classification
so
there's you don't want to see the code
for this it's it's such an outdated
version I it was such a pain to put it
together
um we don't have time to get into it
it's a long story uh let's let's uh make
two more questions and let's let's uh
hit with the uh the actual challenge
okay I'm very happy to answer all your
questions just I would love to show you
what what I prepared for you and then
that's that's it uh sorry you you had
one over there
um well the the the
you know how big your data is it
definitely affects performance we have
tried it with a couple tens of thousands
of data points so for example the Trump
bit it's like 45
000 tweets or something or something and
it works nicely uh we we will actually
use a big data set in the next example
uh and what I do actually you will see
I'll just filter out all the uh columns
that that are not used uh in visual to
avoid it being generated for such a long
time actually it slows down the
generation of the story and uh since
you're you know building something you
don't want to stop all the time waiting
for it to to generate all the different
all the slides and it makes sense to to
try and play with a smaller data set
yeah uh please
yeah yeah yeah so the question I mean
because of the recording just I keep on
forgetting uh so the question was about
texts and how to add text other than the
title uh that's that's a request coming
up very often uh we are thinking about
as you can imagine about a simple
solution and then uh more complex
Solutions so for example I think uh
matplotlib does a great job with this
they have so many different uh quite
straightforward options as I can see
about adding text to to plots uh we we
want to do the same but again the
animation uh poses some new challenges
for doing so but but it makes perfect
sense maybe at first it's going to be
just you know three lines of text
beneath the charts that you can switch
on or off or things like that would that
be enough for you and like for to try or
you need more
the real president
yeah yeah I got you
back to the Chart yeah it makes perfect
sense we are actually thinking about
because there's Jupiter slideshow which
uses uh revealed.js that's been that we
are in slide.com slice.com and uh
integrating with them seems quite
straightforward we are actually in the
process of raising another round of
funding uh when we can do that we would
have more resources to focus on on these
use cases it makes perfect sense and
thanks for asking about it
okay
oh yeah you you yeah yeah I mean we
so integrating this size.com would mean
something like that in my in my view but
we have to talk about it in more detail
mark down slide
um
mm-hmm
okay I'll scribble it down
oh yeah
um it's a great idea I have to talk
about it with our team but thanks for
the thanks for the suggestion uh for the
streamlit thing uh yeah it's not that
nice this URL but if you look for over a
bit and ipivizu I'm pretty sure it will
come out that's the other streaming
example that I mentioned too
um okay can we get started with the
example okay why did I promise that you
might be able to to win some money
um and again not from us but from kaggle
so uh kaggle has this uh survey it does
uh like for the sixth year already uh
they ask data scientists maybe you fill
this survey maybe you just saw it maybe
you skipped it I don't know but there
are like more than 20 000 people uh
filling it out every year and this year
they have a challenge that is about let
me see if it's open here somewhere
uh but it's definitely here
so the challenge is about building a
story uh about uh one of the sub
segments or the sub communities of the
data science Community they have the
data set dating back to 2017 I think
actually the 2017 leadership is a little
bit different but since 2018 it seems
pretty much the same and and they have a
competition that lasts until the end of
this month and we would love to have uh
obviously somebody winning it using
ipadvisor's story we think it's a great
fit we would be happy to help from our
perspective it's even better if somebody
wins it using our tool than if we win it
ourselves honestly it's it's we we don't
build a tool for so long to win I don't
know five or ten thousand bucks with it
but we would love to have you do that
absolutely
so
uh yeah yeah it's everything so if you
just go to the uh this this folder in
the in the visual Workshop travel it's
there's like this is the uh
this is the URL so bit.li uh Slash I5 is
a workshop you have all the links
necessary uh to do that and uh basically
I prepared an initial story for you uh
to show you how I think this data could
be used uh feel free to you know tour it
apart uh feel free to build something
completely from the ground up uh it's
it's all about uh this is an opportunity
to fiddle with with ipivizu also you
would have a purpose in this regard and
I would just love to see what you come
up with sadly we don't have too much
time I took too much time on talking but
uh I'm so let's let's try and do
something with it in the next 15 minutes
or so and those of you who are open for
such a challenge now and then I would
love to you know just keep in touch with
you if you decide to build something I
don't care if you don't submit it to the
competition okay so I really don't want
to push you if you're not that kind of
person it's just an opportunity
that I thought makes sense doing so
and uh the way I I prepared this story
I'll
yeah you can you can look at the
notebook actually most of it is just
preparing this stuff in pandas not very
exciting I actually picked the people
who are younger than 30 years old I mean
it's really uh culturally not right
right to ask peoples about their age
okay I won't uh yeah I'm sorry I'm from
Hungary I keep trying to fit in and uh I
I feel like I'm
it's like a as we call it dancing on
eggs
anyhow I call like categorize people who
are below 30 and who are above 30 and
try to see uh if that affects uh their
like the results within the data set I
actually also prepared for you something
that that you don't have in the original
data set which is uh
the price is yes the spreadsheet of the
survey questions uh and uh it's
a little bit later so there are a couple
uh that aren't not very interesting for
me at least the duration uh everything
else is categories so obviously you have
to have the count uh so that you have
one value and many of the questions are
just fun selection okay so like there's
a series and it tells you like what age
group that person falls into and there's
like 20 of these uh it's a pretty
significant like how much money you earn
or for how long have you been coding how
have you been how long have you been
using ml tools what's your title at work
how big is your how big is the company
you're working for are you a student or
not uh what's your highest educational
level things like that and there are
other types of questions where on which
platform have you begun or completed
data science courses and they basically
added it to
separate Series so there's some
preparation needed to be done in order
to visualize it and you know in in the
right way the example only contains
uh like something that that was in the
like single column questions I'd say and
again so I just categorized the people
who are uh below 30 and above 30 I
sorted the data it's really important
that when you have like temporal data or
you want to sort data better than just
with our by value uh option that I
haven't showcased sorry about that but
it's fairly easy uh you should sort the
data the data frame so I'm just doing it
like I'm sorting the data frame based on
the salary and also on the uh on the
title and uh we'll see you'll see in the
story why it makes sense I'll just check
if everything's all right I uh basically
threw out everything else so that we
have a smaller data frame and then the
visual code starts I'm not going to go
in more detail and here is the the story
that I I prepared throughout the night
so uh
there are around 24 000 answers here
and uh
this is the below 30 above 30.
percentage
these are the gender ratios among these
people uh let's see the shares so
younger people those are that's below 30
is the the bar on the top uh there's a
little bit more ladies and uh and you
know
non-male
participants in that Community uh so I I
definitely would want to check if but if
there is a trend uh here uh with the
with the data set from the previous
years uh then I just switch the category
to student or not student as you can see
like of three quarters of the people
below 30 are students I filtered them
out
and then next up I will just open and
filter out those who didn't provide
salary info so that's why the value
changed and then I would just add uh the
the amount of money people make or say
they make and as you can see uh in the
like the the lower ranges uh Trends look
pretty much the same and above 50 000
per year uh basically people around
below 30 they are just pulling out so
it's it's apparent that there's a lot
less people uh percentage-wise these are
values here I would definitely calculate
percentages instead for for something
that I would submit but but apparently
from the values you can right away see
that there's a there's a trend here and
then the the last view I made is about
onto titles so I now uh edit back the
people who
didn't provide salary info and then
remove the people who uh didn't provide
a title and then I just uh you know show
them by title there's a lot so here's
the text a little too tiny I think it's
interesting that there are some
professions where so the shares are very
different
between below and about 30. it makes a
lot of sense in like with teachers and
professors so it's you know no wonder
there are very few people below their
30s who do that or managers but for
example ML and envelopes Engineers
um people below 30 uh are almost at 30
percent uh 50 sorry whereas uh data
architects it's like literally
non-existent among people who are below
30. I don't know why obviously it's just
it's an interesting Insight I found by
playing with it with this data set and
and if you you know just change the the
initial uh pandas part and figure out
different categories I mean
trying to find the gender pay Gap if
there is any or uh focusing on people
who use more than five tools or uh or
focusing on people who work at companies
that are larger than 500 likes of really
big Enterprises how that affects their
salary their their gender ratio their uh
I don't know how many years they've been
coding so there there are plenty of
opportunities here and I think with our
tool you would be able to do a build a
story fairly easily
now uh as I said this is the first time
I've been doing this it's obvious that I
talk way way too much uh so it's we
already almost towards the very end
um
sorry about that
um I I it's not the first time I fall
into this trap uh
but you had great questions on the other
hand and uh yeah I mean
I would love to how many of you think
that they would try and build something
out of this kaggle or like for kaggle
for this competition I would just like
to understand it's not something you
know I would give you
okay four or five two three six thank
you how many of you think to to play
with this zoo or iPad Vision just give
it a go at home everybody oh I'm so glad
to hear that so uh just one last bit of
I don't know not advice or something but
yeah I just had to reach us so if you go
to ipadvisor.com at least I hope very
much that there is yeah there's a link
to our our Slack
uh it's it's not high enough but yeah
here it is so towards the bottom the
community link
come join our community I am really I'm
personally welcoming everybody who comes
in because I'm so grateful that people
would want to do something with with our
baby you know with the thing that we
were working on and I would love to help
you out I know that learning a new tool
can be very painful I have already
learned you know using the same tool in
a very obscure scripting language in
JavaScript and in Python and it was
painful every time but uh you know at
the end of the day I could stand just
like here and then yesterday and and
show some nice stuff about Donald
Trump's tweets which I would have never
guessed I would do a couple of years
back so uh yeah I'm just happy to and we
and not just me everybody else in the
team we'd be happy to help you through
this initial period of of you know
getting acquainted with vizu and help
you shine in internal company meetings
or at a challenge like this uh and
actually the meeting is is a great way
we have Bloomberg against kanska and
other companies like this where it has
already been used
the feedback we get is that members of
the audience feel smart
so it's it's not just an opportunity for
you to shine and show something really
sexy and and cool but also for members
of the audience to feel empowered and
like okay I know what's the drill I
understand what's going on so if if you
like to have that then then give it a
try
we have still around five six minutes
um and uh just I'd be happy to answer
any questions you still might have thank
you
yep
the engine yeah
yes I think so as I said I'm not a tech
guy I'd be happy to connect you with our
CTO but all I know is that we are using
webassembly so the C plus this engine
runs in the browser and everybody knows
a bit about this they're like wow it's
cool and I'm happy about it and it will
run and it does run so I'm double happy
about it foreign
please
yep
uh yeah uh yes yes there is the way I
would do it is uh add a category uh like
to the data frame uh that uh that is
that has a different value at the
elements that you want to select and at
the elements that you want to not so
and then what I would do is add that
category to the node Channel that I
haven't showed you which would just keep
everything the same and just change the
color now actually add it to the color
channel in a way that that everything
that's not selected becomes gray and
everything that's selected keeps its
original color so it's a little hacky
with the color palette but I I used it
and it works perfectly so for example we
have this story with Rafael Nadal's uh
run on Roland Garros on Reddit
um it was quite popular so it should be
coming
here
oh it's Trump I don't know
yeah here it is so for example here I
already built this with the new
interface and and you'll see that there
are certain matches that I highlight
here uh and and I use that
that's just the quality is awful sorry
I'm
him badly
uh no we we just record our screens so
we will have the option to uh export
video of our thing but right now it's
basically there are either
browser add-ons or you can just record
your screen
so that's about laughing at people
screenshotting their thoughts and adding
it to PPT right
I got caught so that that's the
highlighting I do with the same stuff
um yeah
[Music]
um
any more questions oh yeah sorry
yes yes uh I'm like throughout the other
workshops I might go and find something
nice for my daughter and my wife but in
the in the breaks uh come talk to me I'd
be happy to uh you know continue this
discussion absolutely
and you can see how awesome basically
Natalie is he he won the same grand slam
the most times uh and actually he's the
male athlete who won the same
competition for the most times like he
has the first four positions uh which is
like okay pretty cool and also back in
that view because this was released
right after Roland Garros he was the one
with the most
grand slams in total sorry I'm a bit of
a tennis that nerd or growing to be one
a little bit excited about
that all righty uh we're almost any last
questions
did you like it
thanks